foreign
Seattle to start off this hour hi Zach
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey thanks for having me uh you guys are
so my heroes and it's uh it's real cool
to be on the show
um I had a question for you guys so I
currently
um work at a tech company and I'm
looking to make a career change the
problem is I make really good money
where I'm at right now and what I'm
wanting to go into uh is a significant
pay cut so I make about 110 a thousand
per year right now uh with potential to
move up I just started the company so
there's there's a lot of growth there
but I I'm not a fan of what I do I took
Ken Coleman's career assessment gave me
some great ideas and what I'm wanting to
go into is firefighting which starting
salary is about 30 000 less a year
um and we're currently in baby step two
and we've got um with snowballing things
it'll probably take a year or less to
get everything paid off
um from kind of the snowball calculator
we did on your guys website so uh my
question is should I wait to do any sort
of career change until I've got baby
step two taken care of three to six
months in uh savings fund and then a
down payment for a house while I have
the higher paying career or do I take
the risk and go to a lower paying job
and kind of take longer to get you know
uh our finances all set up and in down
payment for a house because that's
ultimately where we'd like to go that
makes sense
so you want to abandon a perfectly safe
computer and run into burning houses
[Laughter]
and I'm like I want to do something
that's meaningful to me and that sounds
a heck of a lot more meaningful have you
have you gone on a ride along yet or
have you do you have buddies here
firefighters
yeah so I got a buddy that's a
firefighter
um I've been doing a lot of research
into the career itself kind of what it
the day-to-day looks like and all of it
kind of fires me up the people I've
talked to have loved it everyone that's
kind of in public service I got an uncle
that's a cop he's like I wish I had been
a firefighter but a lot of positive
things about it from the kind of the
research I've been doing so far okay
all right yeah I would do the
ride-alongs too by the way but um yeah
um
what does the on-ramp look like how much
training how much down time
you you walk out of 110 and you walk
into 80 is that what we said or 70 what
was it yeah you walk into uh they have
it all scaled out so it's 82. okay so
you're going to walk out of 110 walk
into 82 day one or after training or day
one for mine they're gonna pay you that
while they train you
yeah because you have to go to fire
school is that what they call it yeah
yeah so it's about 16 weeks it's from
what I believe it's 82 it might be a
little less than that but it's within
that ballpark regardless
um where it's about a 30 000 pay cut
yeah yeah and are you married
yeah married three kids
um all under the age of four which day
at home mom she stay at home yeah she
stay home because the plan just keeps
that way so okay can you make your
budget on that
uh yes it'll just take longer to do the
things we want
um well after 16 weeks uh you have what
firefighters call an extra job
because you generally work three on and
you build decks you're paying houses on
the other four
right most firefighters I know make as
much on their side gig as they do
fighting fires because they got this
wonderful schedule blocks set aside
yeah I know one guy made a hundred grand
building decks last year
and I had a buddy who was uh got
certified while he was in fire academy
for I don't have me that [ __ ] that's
cool well welding or uh some kind of
engineer I don't know he got some kind
of incredible certifications where he's
making a jillion dollars on the side
yeah yeah so you're you're not gonna
work three Beyond four all four you're
gonna work three and you're gonna work
four
yeah yeah that's the plan that's that's
the other so your income's not going
down side Hustle
yeah it's true so you need to also
engineer your side Hustle
uh self-employed opportunity because you
can control the schedule and you can
work around and if you're going to paint
houses you just let them know I'm not
going to be there those three days
that's my fire gig and right you know
and um you know again I think you'll
find around the firehouse that's a
pretty standard operation
so let me let me throw this at you
I always want folks who have multiple
kids like you do under the age of three
four or five
to Exhale for a minute
because everything in your life feels
chaotic you feel like you have no
purpose because you're funding the lives
of three kids who are too young to even
recognize you exist other than you make
them get in the bath and they don't want
to do that and change their underwear
semi-regularly and they don't want to do
that either and there's something about
you start searching for a place where
you can find meaning it's not at your
home
and so I Dave I I would I would tell you
if you were just my buddy and we're just
hanging out I would tell you get
yourself do a year Sprint and get out of
debt at least take that brick out of
your backpack at least take that
that
um that anxiety producing thing in your
life take it off the table and in the
meantime do some ride-alongs get to um
reading about firefighting is one thing
holding somebody in their front yard
while their house burns down or pulling
somebody out of a building and trying to
get them onto an EMS truck is a totally
different thing some people are wired
for that some people are not and so
you're in a unique position where you
could experience that and not have to
before you've you know completely jumped
off the dock
um but that'd be my recommendation to
you not a bad idea go serve man I love
that idea we need more firefighters and
police officers out there yeah thank you
for your willingness yeah I think the
um your side gig might be your
technology thing rather than building
decks or painting houses I might have
been wrong on that first wave it could
be incredible yeah because I mean
apparently you can work from home and
not work much see and get her like a job
doing that and stuff